yo i just gotta pause and say
this is the best theory i've heard thus
far
i am so engrossed yeah what is going on
there citizens the reject nation john
how is it going i'm great how are you do
oh you asked me what that's not how this
goes oh all right guys we're gonna watch
from our buddy ryan airy for screen
crush king's plan what is it in the
multiverse saga love me some ryan airy
videos and uh guys just wanted to give a
quick mention in case you haven't heard
real rejects heavy spoilers and screen
crush have partnered together to bring
you a one-stop nerd shop for all of our
apparel combined ryanair screen crush
himself has himself an amazing shirt it
is awesome envious of the idea guys we
also have our merch up there as well i
want to thank everyone who has gone over
there and bought some stuff because
whatever you guys get supports the
channel obviously we looked at the sales
today and they were actually pretty
awesome so thank you guys and showed up
and speaking of king we have a we have a
special shirt that we are debuting uh
relatively soon so shop zero edition dot
com you can go check out everything we
got to offer over there thank you guys
once again and thank you to of course
ryan airy and paul
heavy spoilers is his last name let's
see what this plan is mr theory boy
it means that you would enter a quantum
realm what does that mean it means that
you would enter a reality where all
concepts of time and space
become irrelevant
good setup good tease good back to
screen crush i'm ryan airy kang the
conqueror is the big bad of the mcu's
multiverse saga the one who's going to
battle the avengers for the fate of the
multiverse and the kang dynasty and
secret wars luckily we won't have to
wait that long for kang to arrive
jonathan majors is returning as kang the
conqueror in quantum mania
according to the comic book trailer he
is the main villain of the third ant-man
movie but that's not all kang is
actually in the quantum realm or what's
it doing there and how does that connect
to the martial saga well obviously it
has something to do with time travel the
quantum realm is how you travel through
time and kang is all about the sweet
sweet time but we think there is
something far bigger at play kang's
master plan is going to be far more
ambitious than just time travel the
quantum realm is the key for everything
ant-man 3 might have just become one of
the most important movies in the
multiverse saga hey hey
you know who confirmed it is
peyton reed
he said something or another here's the
quote about it being important or a game
changer or i'm contributing to the video
ant-man is the most important now watch
it come out and have nothing almost to
do with it yeah there's a bunch of
marvel [ __ ] again phase five has no
direction so in the comic-con trailer
for quantum mania we see that the ant
squad are sucked into the quantum realm
i guess that after end game hank and
janet are investigating the realm
something goes wrong with their
experiment and now they're all stuck in
the quantum realm again
oh
not again
up until now the quantum realm seemed to
be mostly empty the only life then it
were the tardigrades with strange micro
bug creatures make sure you yeah i know
the name of that tardigrade field
they're cute but they'll eat you those
are real the trailer shows that there
are people inside the quantum realm now
both of the human and alien variety this
is something that was hinted at in
ant-man the waters groundhog day happens
in the quantum realm they pass this tiny
bubble city janet must have spent more
time in that city which explains how she
survived those 30 years in the quantum
realm
probably got it on with some people in
there while you wait for hank pam to
show up dude she's probably been with
like 12 different kang berries
it's like a whole hero gas mechanic gang
train coming in
so the mcu's quantum realm is an
amalgamation of two separate dimensions
from the comics the quantum zone and the
microverse the latter is the home of the
micronauts a superhero team that lives
in the microrealm the microverse was
created and inhabited by a time
traveling group that went back in time
from the very far future marvel will
most likely go in a similar direction
for the residents of this bubble city
with kang being their ruler now in case
you didn't know kang comes from the
future a variant of myself lived on
earth in the 31st century kang is
nathaniel richards a scientist from the
30th century who discovered great
footage
oh and this city is probably chronopolis
in the comics it's kang city it's his
base of operations from where he rules
all of his other realms so as per usual
marvel is combining tons of different
things from the comics so what all of
this means is that kang is actively
conquering the entire quantum realm and
we have a theory on what kangas planning
that we're going to go over in just a
moment first let's take a look at kang's
menacing speech to scott since his words
give us some hints about his plan they
also give us a hint of what kind of kang
we'll meet in quantum mania and that's
important because we have no idea which
kang variant this will be that's the
thing with kang there are countless
infinite versions of them and each
variant is different oh my god i want
that king
just the one white guy who's the big
white eyes oh my god get richard jenkins
to play this guy i can see it happening
oh yeah i want it or freaking uh not
richard jenkins christopher lloyd
christopher lloyd played this guy it's
about time he did an mcu i could totally
see it happening i'll get danny trejo oh
dude just start a bucket list of all the
gangs you want to see as different
actors gang don't text
kang improvises
king conkers
so the gist of kang speech is how time
is not a straight line the timeline is
not linear it is a loop that's how the
sacred timeline appeared in loki kang
then tells scott that he has seen
everything that will happen he knows how
it all ends and that is exactly how he
who remains saw time he literally had a
script for everything that ever happened
and will happen he doesn't perceive time
in a linear way like most beings in the
multiverse he experiences every moment
at once that's a flat surface
i know it all
and i've seen it all so from kang's
speech
he perceives time similarly to he who
remains that might be because this
variant took over the time variant's
authority as we've seen at the end of
loki or perhaps he didn't unlock this
god-like ability just yet and what kang
actually means is he explored every
corner of the timeline he has traveled
into countless timelines the time travel
rules in the mcu make it clear that
every trip to the past creates a new
timeline if you travel to the past that
past becomes your future
and your former present becomes the past
but that's where the miss marvel episode
threw kind of a wrench in the whole time
travel thing you know yeah remember how
that caused a big fiasco
riots in the streets people petitioning
the disney building in burbank
california the rules go and fix your
cinematic universe
and restore the batgirl movie they were
saying at the disney lot they were all
confused on what's going on ah deal and
below directed both what do we do what
do we do
multiverse incursion event
but no you're you're right ryan though
let's just go off of what endgame said
that's the ultimate cannon right there
as long as kang doesn't interfere with
the time stream too much he can just
observe and see what happens in every
moment of time and this is confirmed by
the ending of the trailer as ant-man
meets kang scott says that he's an
avenger so kang is messing with the
wrong guy
hi
i'm scott i don't even know who you are
no you wouldn't have heard of me
kang's response is just perfectly cold
and dismissive he simply asks you are an
avenger have i killed you before so this
means that kang fought the avengers
before and that he killed them all i
love this
i hope he delivers it the way you
delivered it ryan
you're an avenger i fought you before i
love this he's so perky
everyone i've heard do that line is like
you're an avenger have i killed you
before before everyone puts on their
josh brolin yeah
you're an avenger
you're an adventurer
if i killed you before
no way
don't trust this nice guy act i know
this man
this means that kang has been traveling
throughout time and space exploring
other timelines and he killed the
avengers so many times at this point
killing earth's mightiest heroes is an
afterthought he can't even remember
which ones he's killed so when kang
faces the avengers in kang dynasty he
already knows everything about them he
will predict each of their moves counter
every one of their attacks this is a
battle he experienced countless times
before
you time sliding son of a [ __ ] so this
makes me believe that the kang variant
we'll see in quantum mania is going to
be the main kang who will fight the
avengers in phase six oh fascinating
this movie is a type of an origin story
for kang we're going to see how this
kang becomes the biggest baddie in the
multiverse but remember so far the
quantum realm is only used for time
travel but we're fairly certain that the
quantum realm is both the key for
traveling both through time and the
multiverse there's a clear visual
parallel between the quantum realm and
the way the multiverse is depicted the
multiverse is always represented by this
crystallic glass we see it in the
watchers nexus of all realities as well
as whenever the barriers between
universes shatter the same glass effect
appears in no way home when reality
shatters and in the portals america
chavez creates a similar crystallized
glass appears inside the quantum realm
we see it when scott shrinks to the very
bedrock of reality such cool visuals i
know it's getting rolled in
and we saw doctor strange in the same
dimension and the ancient ones electric
kool-aid yes you made your point
the material
it all fits so what i'm getting at is
that the quantum realm is a gateway not
just for time travel but for the whole
multiverse so it's the key for it all
and here is what kang is planning the
reason why he wants to rule the quantum
realm is because drum roll please
can anybody guess he wants to create his
very own
sacred timeline the sacred time
eons ago there was a multiversal war
between the kang variants reality almost
ended he who remains isolated a
collection of realities from the
multiverse creating the sacred timeline
i actually like already where you're
going with this i've heard several
theories about what king's role might be
in ant-man quantum mania and one thing
that often gets brought up is guys you
got to remember that there's multiple
kings and multiple king variants so that
might not even be the king that we see
ultimately in kang dynasty who's the
real big baddie of the mcu but i
actually prefer the method of
introducing not a kang variant but the
thing to kick off the mcu so yeah you
know if the theories are floating about
about them there might be a major death
i'm opting for hank pym being that major
death in ant-man quantomania i know
people like the film theorists are
opting for you know uh paul rudd
scotland scotland's name mascot pilgrim
scotland that's a big thing that people
have been talking about lately but where
you're going with this
sounds just like much more different
than what we've gotten with the mcu
where it's like yeah you kind of check
in and we reminded that there's a thanos
or there's a thanos here but a phase
five is really you're watching king's
manipulation throughout all of the
movies especially that being the kickoff
film quantum mania i think that's just a
much more compelling way to go
absolutely agree now that he who remains
as dead that same multiverse war is
going to start all over again multiverse
of madness established the incursions as
the threat to the multiverse encouraging
an incursion occurs when the boundary
between two universes erodes and they
collide destroying one
or both
entirely incursions wipe out holes
didn't know what he was talking about
now we went over all of that in this
video so feel free to check that out
later anyway no kang variant is safe in
this war each one of their universes
could be destroyed at any given moment
all of their traveling in between
universes triggered incursions so they
have no choice but to fight each other
it's the only way they can survive the
war but someone is coming countless
different versions of a very dangerous
person and they're all set on war we
need to prepare and this is why kang is
in the quantum realm this reality is a
separate universe a one-of-a-kind
dimension in the whole of existence the
quantum realm is a passage
the bedrock of the multiverse a place
where time and space are irrelevant if
that's the case it means that the
quantum realm is safe from incursions
kang goes there because it's the one
place he's safe from his other variants
sure if his universe is hit by an
incursion then it will be wiped out but
he will survive
nicely done but kang is a conqueror he's
not planning to hunker down and hide
forever he who remains the hunkerer to
protect his timeline from incursions by
creating the sacred timeline and that's
what kang wants to achieve he wants to
protect his universe a universe where he
rules the past present and future his
only way to win and survive the
multiverse of war and the quantum realm
is the key once i isolated our timeline
all i have to do is manage the flow of
time
and prevent any further branches now we
don't know exactly how he achieved that
when he says eliath was part of it or
maybe he simply used elias to wipe out
all the other timelines i weaponized
goliath and i ended i ended the
multiversal war it's up to
interpretation and i'm sure marvel is
going to explain it however they wish
but i assume that on his travels kang
found some clues that pointed him to the
quantum realm the trailer shows that
kang is building or using some kind of
ring device inside the realm it looks
like a rotating gimbal this sort of
reminds me of the mobius strip from
endgame the one which tony used to solve
time travel kang might be building a
super quantum computer that will be
powered by quantum energy do you guys
just put the word quantum in front of
everything all of that power will go
into isolating the whole universe from
the multiverse well unless it's a type
of death star that he's going to use to
blow up other universes from the quantum
realm wouldn't put it past the mcu to go
in this direction it's another death
star for why is so important for
creating the sacred timeline well you
see the dimension is a gateway between
timelines and universes meaning that in
the entire multiverse there is but one
quantum realm it's sort of like the
bedrock of reality
[Music]
for example look how hank pym described
the realm you would enter a reality
where all concepts of time and space
become irrelevant which is similar to
how time works in the tva you know time
passes differently here in the tva
meaning that the tva could actually be
located in the quantum realm
cool used its energy to create the
sacred timeline then he put the tva in
charge of policing that sacred timeline
ensuring that everything that needs to
happen will happen and eliminate
potential nexus events which could
branch off the timeline kang took over
the tva and loki that means that he must
be aware of all this if the tva does
indeed exist in the quantum realm then
it means that kang controls a godlike
power just look at what he who remains
was able to do he was able to nullify
any superpowers and magic anyone with
the tva neck brace becomes completely
powerless we see something similar to
that in multiverse of madness though
those were created by christine with the
magic relic i developed those using the
sands of nisanti also remember how
sylvie can't use her magic in the tva
headquarters
she didn't have one of those neck braces
but she was still powerless even the
infinity stones were nerfed inside the
tva some of the guys use them as
paperweights yo
i just gotta pause and say
this is the best theory i've heard thus
far
i'm so engrossed yeah i was just getting
wrapped up in that that would actually
just tie up so much of that one
cliffhanger that we got of loki season
one
and explain it all the way relatively
quick yeah and then maybe with he who
remains gone yeah like it's the the
quantum realm is free for another gang
to come in and take it and i mean what
he's saying here like
now that i'm hearing it it makes the
most sense to me that yeah like the
quantum realm would be the one constant
across all these multiverses that then
not only would be important for time
travel but probably would be important
to like the ultimate
solution like you know
there's like so many different ways to
traverse between timelines and and you
know the different facets of the
universe but like the way that they're
touting this as being like ant-man's
most important movie and a very
important movie to the avengers he keeps
saying bedrock and i feel like this
could get into the roots
of how the entire thing
works if they you know conceive it well
enough and then that makes me okay what
is loki season two going to explore in
this
space between all of times because that
gives us a big clue about the tva as
well this sort of floating thing within
the quantum realm that you know again
anybody could take hold or influence
over so it does really seem like if you
want to be the god who controls this
whole universe you go to the quantum
franchise yeah yeah and i think that's
the best picture he's painting so far he
who remains found a way to weaponize
quantum energy in a way that negates all
other energies now imagine that in kang
dynasty the avengers battle kang but he
just creates some quantum bubble around
himself nullifying all of their attacks
even the combined power of thor doctor
strange captain marvel and the scarlet
witch won't make a dent is this the
greatest power in the universe
despite all of that power he who remains
has one kryptonite the same one k will
have if he creates the sacred timeline
everything on the sacred timeline is
pre-ordained even he who remains was
still a slave to it just like everyone
else in it he lacked free will we see
that in this moment we just crossed
the threshold now the meaning of
crossing the threshold is still a
mystery but what this moment means is
that he who remains no longer knew what
was coming next every moment past the
threshold was not preordained in the
sacred timeline but now i have no idea
no idea how the rest of this is going to
go and for some reason at that moment
the sacred timeline begins to branch off
again even before silvi kills he who
remains that may be because up to this
point he who remains controlled the
sacred timeline but once they crossed
the threshold he wasn't in control
anymore every decision made by anyone in
the timeline is now causing it to branch
off into infinity a single choice
created a whole new hero
there
that's the moment
that created a new universe that would
make actually so much sense when feige
was saying that
everything that we've been seeing that's
been taking place a lot of it is due to
the events of loki season two that they
will explain how that's possible like
with doctor strange and multiverse of
madness how breaking through the
multiverses is occurring or maybe even
the existence of america chavez oh yeah
and even spider-man no way home a
million percent you can see how this is
all linked to it as well like suddenly
i'm like oh my god you can see you know
it was kind of like figured that yeah
the way it's being illustrated here yeah
is making it so much clearer where i'm
like the direction has always been there
yeah
right and then you think whoa
totally and then you think okay so loki
season one we were doing a lot of setup
and we had to get loki to a certain
point but now from loki season two we
could probably survey the whole
multiverse from here yeah because a lot
of it always was leading to how is this
happening that's always the question
that one of the characters is having
like okay now we know what's happening
but it but how yeah and it's like the
further we get the more it feels like
yeah the loki the timeline breaks and
everything we've seen in phase four is
just more and more branches setting up
to yeah collide
maybe not everything but a lot of things
a lot of things
that means that there is a far greater
power at play something beyond he who
remains and that is what kang really
needs to solve he needs a way to control
the sacred timeline even beyond the
threshold the way to do that is to
control time in a way that he who
remains couldn't that means being able
to travel through time without creating
a branching timeline so we're talking
about time travel that allows you to go
back in time and just just actually go
past it
ken could see beyond the threshold and
change his past accordingly this way he
always wins because time is always on
his side now there is a way to change
the past without creating a new timeline
and that is with the time stone but as
we've seen in what if there are some
serious strings attached to the time
stone the type of strings that destroy
universes i'm creating a paradox you're
risking the universe you cannot reverse
an absolute point also i just don't
think the infinity stones will play a
major role in the multiverse saga in the
comics dr doom created a device which
allows him to travel back in time
without creating a new timeline and
actually he can affect his own past this
device is called a doom lock and kang is
likely trying to create something
similar inside the quantum realm but
it's highly unlikely that kang will be
successful in creating his own sacred
timeline this is because of the comic
stories that avengers 5 and 6 will be
based on so the kang dynasty comic has
nothing to do with the multiverse so the
story is going to be heavily changed for
the mcu so i wager that the main source
of inspiration for avengers 5 will
actually be time runs out event yeah
exactly yes
yes that story is avengers 6. just
before reality ended dr doom took the
god-like power of the beyonders and used
it to create battle world so that's a
patchwork reality consisting of the
surviving universes i'm pretty sure the
quantum realm will end up being the
mcu's battle world in the kang dynasty
will take control of the quantum realm
but the avengers and his own variants
will thwart his master plan of creating
his own sacred timeline but the
incursions will collapse reality and the
multiverse will end but right before
that kang will use all of that quantum
energy to transform the quantum realm
into battle world and that is how kang
will save reality you're welcome
he will rule the remnants of reality as
a god so it'll be up to the avengers to
stop him and then use the realm to
restart the multiverse and that is the
importance of the quantum realm for the
multiverse saga that is what we believe
is kang's master plan but what do you
think about all this let me know in the
comments
me on twitter that's like interesting
subscribe smash that bell for alerts for
screen crush i'm ryan airy
[Music]
because yeah at that point it was
brilliant man oh my goodness and then
the the quantum realm will be like the
level playing field where they can you
know have the showdown and then kang
gets to be both the savior but even more
of the villain
like it's crazy but i want doctor doom
everybody wants doctors they're having
fantastic fours show up like a few
movies beforehand you think they get
knocked out
could very much see dr doom swooping in
as like your switcheroo like i'm here to
bail you guys out but that's going to
come back invite you later you give a
whole big role to kang
in the comics dr doom created battle
world come on again like i feel like all
bets are off on one hand because of the
multiverse like we could totally see a
battle world assembled by kang but the
other part of me goes like i don't know
if people would be willing to i feel
like there are a lot of changes people
will give the benefit of the doubt to i
don't know if that's one of them well
i don't know all i know is ryan you put
together an amazing video that was a
seriously a great video man
so thank you guys for being here uh
subscribe to screen crush you haven't
done so you could check out our shop
zero zeroaddition.com i only need to say
shop once i said twice there
stop shop twice let's end this with a
page
maria hammond
my dear
she bought a shirt from shops zero
edition
we got that fresh drip i don't know if
you want us to show your face on screen
and i don't want to get in trouble for
doing that but we're gonna blur your
face out but you're rocking one of our
t's you could be anyone but that tea
couldn't that he actually sold out and
you're one of the lucky people to get
that final t so i want to thank you
thank you from the bottom of my heart
for supporting us at our patreon
supporting us
in this apparel venture we have ventured
into with the venturing and then also
thank you so much for supporting us
just as human beings we have human
rights too so i appreciate how much um
so much consideration you throw away and
how much thoughtfulness goes into
everything you do when it comes to us so
thank you for being just an amazing
spirit and a wonderful
human being i love you dear love you
maria
[Music]